A COUPLE OF REAL GOOD LOOKS
AGAINST THE RANGERS THE OTHER
DAY TO TORONTO TO OTTAWA
AND BACK TO -- THOMAS Y PICKS I
OFF BY CONNOR BROWOW AND THAT
SHOT LIFTED HIGH AND WIDE BYBOL.
PLAYS IT BACK FREDERICK GAUDREA
GOES UP AND OUT OFK TO FIALA.
UMBER 7,
MINOR PENALTY, SSON EK
WITH THE REDIRECT.
AND PAUL IS
SHORT-ED BREAK
GUY
LIKE ALEX FORMENTON WHO IS WON'.
>> Jamie: THIS IS A L TKACHUK.
TKACHUK WORKS IT BACK, CONNOR
BROWN A
THE REBOUND, TRY TO FIRE A BAD
SHORT STOP
>> Gord: GAUDREAU AWAY BY
FORSBERG.
STU
KULIKOV AND ON  RIGHT BY BRANNS.
TRIED TO GET INTO AND
IN FRONT.
TKACHUK HEAD U U
GAUDREAU, FEEDS IT BACK ACROSS,
IN, SHOOTS, FORSBERG MAD
DECIDES TO GO FIVE-HOLE QUICKLY.
STURM, HEAD UP T
STREET, SCORES!
HARTMAN TO SPURGEON TO THE BACK
OF THE NET AND THE GAME IS TIED
BAR ONACK TO
JOSH BROWN, SCORES!
OTTAWA RETAKES THE  HOP AND
JUST WIRES THIS GLOVE SIDE PASTD
BY FORSBERG!
GREAT PAD
THE FRONT OF THE NET, AND RIGHT
ENNIS CHOPS AT IT, BAC
GATHERS IT BACK UP.ICK HIS SPOT.
HE'S GOING TO SCORE HISBACK DOW.
BOUNCES BACK UP TO FIALA, A HAR
FORMENTON TO SHOW SPEED,
COMPOSURE, STICKS
IT.
BRANNSTROM, UP AHEAD OFF BY INJ.
MINNESOTA WERE WINLESS IN FIVE
UP
BRODIN. BRODIN ACROSS TO
SPURGEON.
SPURG